- [Narrator] The economic
ruptures caused by Russia's war
in Ukraine triggered a
string of street protests
in Moldova over the past
few months, and recently led
to the collapse of the country's
pro-European government.
Another pro-western prime
minister, Dorin Recean,
took over on Thursday
amid heightened security threats linked
to the war next door.
That's because the former Soviet Republic
is strategically important to both Russia
and Ukraine as the war rages on.
Here's why.
Moldova is a small,
landlocked country sandwiched
between Romania and the West
and Ukraine to the east.
It has a population smaller
than that of Chicago
and the third lowest GDP per
capita of any European country.
Its already struggling economy
has taken a hit since
war broke out in Ukraine.
Inflation has soared
amid Moscow's decision
to squeeze natural gas supplies,
prompting a wave of street protests,
and Russian attacks on the electrical grid
in Ukraine have led to power
cuts for its tiny neighbor,
while an influx of Ukrainian refugees
has strained Moldova's public services.
The situation comes at a time
when the country is cooperating closely
with NATO and seeking to
join the European Union.
- It is on a real
pro-reform, anti-corruption
and European path.
- [Narrator] This has
worsened Moldova's relations
with Russia.
Some pro-Western politicians
in Moldova and Ukraine
have accused the Kremlin
of planning a coup to
destabilize the country.
(Volodymyr speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] On February 9th,
Ukraine's president said
he had shared intelligence
with his Moldovan counterpart
about an alleged Russian scheme
to topple her country's
democratic system of government.
A day later, Moldova's
pro-Western government collapsed
citing the economic challenges
brought on by the war.
And not long after that,
the country's president said
she had confirmed details
of Zelenskyy's statement
and that Russia's plan included attacks
on government buildings
and taking hostages.
(Maia speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Russia dismissed
the allegations as unfounded,
saying Ukraine was
attempting to draw Moldova
into a confrontation with Moscow.
The US said it hadn't been able
to independently confirm
the alleged coup plot.
- What I'll say about that
is deeply concerning reports,
certainly not outside the
bounds of Russian behavior
- [Narrator] A destabilized
Moldova is in Russia's interest
according to one analyst
and could pose a security
threat to Western Ukraine.
Russia has troops stationed
in the breakaway region of Transnistria.
The thin strip of land on
Moldova's eastern border
with Ukraine is run by
pro-Russian separatists.
If Ukraine had to allocate
resources to counter that threat,
it could diminish the chances
of success in the southeast
of the country the analysts said.
These factors raised fears
that the war could spill
out beyond Ukraine's borders
and highlight the important
role Moldova might play
for both sides in the coming months.
(pensive music)